No joo, arskaterve.
No semmoinen asia tuli tossa mieleen, ku hakkasin tossa hellappuita,
ja istuin pelkyn päälle sätkälle, etten tota, oli sata vuotta vaan keksintä, ku häkäpöntty auto.
Että sehän se ois, nyt tämän päivän asia, ku tota, pensahinta o.
Ja nii se oli kaks ja puol euroa litraja.
Eihän sitä enää varaa kelleen semmoisia, täällä hankaa köyrää maalaisäijää, semmoisia pensahintoa, joo enää varaa maksalla.
Tämmöne häkätäntö auto, sehän on tosiaan helikatisevä, ja ilimasta ajeluahan se ois, nyt sitten, ku semmoisella körmyyttelis tuolla.
Että ilman muuta tämmönen pitäis saaha nyt äkkiä sarjatuotantoa, nii.
Tämä ois semmoinen, meille ainakin perse aukisille maalaisäijille kiireettöminen uvoille, nii se ois ihan huippu keksitel, ku pääsis körmyyttelis tuossa selliohite, ja kahtelis, ku muut makselee.
Kalliita pensakoluja, etä tota, hyvät kuntoria, tota, miettikää.
Jokainen nyt tykönäsee, mitä työ maksatte, vaikka vuositasolla pensasta, nii, sitä tavalla. No hei, hei.
No siinä viesti sinulle, jolla on mahdollisuudet rueta valmistamaan ja tuottamaan häkäpöntöautoja, kuten juuri kuultiin, sille saattaisi olla markkinat.
Se on kansanradioja, Lasse Olkinoira tässä tervehdys.
Ja kysymys kuuluu, tai oikeastaan kysymykset, että oletko sinä koskaan pohtinut, että miksi kuka muu ei osaa ajaa?
Oletko sinä koskaan harmitellut, kun televisiossa näkyy aina vaan ne samat naamat?
Ja haluatko sinä antaa kiitokset eläinsuojeluyhdistysten työntekijöille ja vapaaehtoisille?
Jos vastaus on yhteenkään kysymykseen kyllä, niin et ole ainoa, kuten nyt tässä alkavassa jaksossa kuullaan.
Muutkin asiat ne tässä maassa mietityttää, annetaan kansanradion soittaneiden kertoa.
Et silleet. Moi.
Teen tässä tämmöstä ihan omakohtaistavaan kirjanpitoa.
Sytä, mitä meillä menee ruokaa ja tällä lailla.
Tällä lailla, mutta ruvetkaapaise ihmiset kattomaan ihan oikeasti, listaamaan, mitä teidän ruokalasten nämä on.
Ja siinä tämä alvi, tämä vero.
Siis, miten joka ikisestä asiasta, mitä ostat, maksat, alvia? Ja, tota, se tekee kulkares kulkaes aika paljon. Että siitä vaan, veroja keräämää nii. Että moi.
Joo, tuota, Nonni, hautavari vaan tätä hyvinkää, että soittaa päivää, ja olen eläkeläinen ja sellainen komennusmies.
Ja olen, tuota, Nonni, ollut kovasti tekemisissä tämän Kelan ja Keusote ja näiden systeemien kanssa, ja pankkien kanssa, ja tällaisten kanssa, tuota, Noi, ja.
Tämä esimerkiksi Kela ja Keusote kohtelee kansalaisiaan todella törkeesti.
Niillä ei oo minkäänlaista tolkkua tässä asiassa, mitä minuaki koskee, ja mul on tuttava piiri, ja ykski on, tuota, Nonni, haastanut Kelaani, tuota, Nonni, tuota, Nonni.
Viis kertaa oikeuteen Kelaan näistä asioista, kun ei saa oidettua niitä asioita ollenka.
Ja sitten kaikki kuulee kaiken maailman tilioitteita, ja kaikkea tällaisia pitää lähettää.
Monetki ihmiset, jotka siellä joutuu käymään, niin on koko ikäset tehneet töitä, maksaneet veroja, elättäneet pankkeja, kaikkea tällasta.
Kelaan ei pääse, tuota, noin, ollenkaan, kaksi kertaa viikossa, tuota, noin, hyvinkäälläkin.
Sit on tullut sellaisia, näistä asiakkaista ja vanhemmista ihmisistä on tullut sellaisia supikoiria.
Ne ovat sellaisia kerieläisiä, ne on laitettu kerijäämään keusotelta ja kelalta rahaa.
Eipä tässä muuta, kiitos, ei.
Kansanradiotervehdys.
No, tervehdys, täällä ois Teemo Nuutinen Tuusulasta.
Teemo Tuusulasta.
O, terve, terve Lasse.
Onko teilläkin Tuusulassa tuulinen päivä?
Oon se vähän, joo, kyllä, täälläkin. Siihen me voida vaikuttaa millään tavalla, mutta me voidais vaikuttaa tähän Venäjän johtajan vähän.
Meidän johtajat vois vähän vaikuttaa.
Miten tää Vladimir Ras puuttinut tänne Suomeen opiskelemaan, miten demokratia toimii?
Tänne opiskelemaan, pitäiskö sitä varten perustaa ihan joku erillinen koulu vai laitetaanko se jo valmiiks?
Varmaan ois ihan leikikoulu.
Leikikoulu?
Aloittaa sieltä ihan ala asti, ihan esikoulusta.
Esikoulusta lähtien?
No, koko peruskuntelä opiskelee vähän, miten demokratia toimii oikeasti.
Vaikki puolueet on mukana. Neuvostoliitto on edelleen tosiasia, se on edelleen olemassa. Niin on vaan muuttunut, ja lippu.
Minä tykkäsin tuosta, mitä sanoit, että mitäpä sitä säätä murehtimaan, kun siihen ei voi vaikuttaa, keskitytään niihin, joihin voi.
No, nii, ei voi, ei nii. Sää valittaa säätä vaikka kuika, mutta eipä se voi voida autoa.
Nii, nii, se on totta, kyllä.
Joo, no nii, eli puuttiin peruskouluun, ja säätä siedetään sellaisena, kun se on. Minkäs teet? Minä kiitän tästä puhelusta, Teema.
No, no ei mitää, joo, joo. Heikinä hyvää sytsöä sitten.
Kiitos sinulle myös.
Tossa yhdessä puhelussa mainittiin, kuinka hyvinkään Kela on auki vain kahtena päivänä viikossa, asiakaspalvelu siellä siis toimii kahtena päivänä viikossa, ja oma toiminen asiointi asiakastilassa maanantaista perjantaihin.
Sähköpostia on saapunut nimimerkillä "Pienen auton taistelussa voittanut".
Jatkuvasti kuulen narinaa, miten naiset, erityisesti vanhat naiset, hidastelevat parkkipaikoilla, milloin on väärinpäin ajettu, ja lähtiessä kuluu aikaa, tai ajavat isolla autolla.
Vaimon on ajattava sillä isolla autolla, kun Siippa ei voi pienellä autolla ajaa.
Ja jos vanhat naiset ajavat varovasti ja hitaasti, niin ajavat vanhat miehetkin hitaasti, ja syöksyvät kieletystä paikasta suoraan eteen.
Ratin takaa näkyi vain lippalakki ja vihainen naama.
Eräskin mies kurvasi edestäni niin, että auto heilahti, ja auton etuosaan tuli lommo.
Hän syöksyi autosta vihaisena sättimään minua, kun olin kuulemma peruttanut hänen autonsa päälle.
Taitava olen, kun auton etuosan kolhin peruttamalla, näe siis nimimerkki pienen auton taistelussa voittanut.
Täällä paappa, joka alkaa kyllästyä kaikenlaiseen valtion kynimiseen.
Kun pitää uusia turhaa ajokortti-henkilökortti, eikä tuo henkilökortitiedot ole koko elämän ajan sama ilman noita turhia uusintoja.
Esimerkiksi pankit ei anna asiakkaalleen omia rahoja, jos et ole henkilökorttia.
Eli jos et uusi henkilökorttia, tässä tapauksessa olisi paras ottaa rahat omaan käyttöön.
Ja siinä arkkaarian vään asiakkaalle pohojeita, lopettakaa se kansan kyniminen.
No nii, Lapinukko soittaa kansan radioon. Minulla lähenee 80 vuosipäivä, ja minun pitäs ajokortti uusia.
Ja terveystalolla ei ole täällä keskilopisena toimistoa. Minut neuvotti Mehiläiseen, minä menin sinne, ja siellä tilasin ajan, ja ootin viikon, ja nykkä pääsin sinne.
Ni, siellä tuli semmoneen, joka sano olevansa, lääkeri, joka tekee, pidi tehdä terveystarkastus.
Nee, mitähän, mutta tekiinko kaivana netistä minun elämän, kokot, kirjon, missä minä olen ollut, mitä minä olen tehnyt, ei mitään terveystarkastusta.
Ja sitten, sanooko nii puoli tuntia puhunut paskaa, minä saatte, kyllä, minä tiedän, mitä minä olen tehnyt elämässä, ei mulle tarvitse sitä netistä kaivaa.
Ni, siellä sanoi, ettei menei tuolta konttorin kautta, ettei saat maksulla, puu, minä saatte, minä maksan, mitä tästä, en penniäkään, en euroakaan, en senttiäkään.
Kyllä on elämä mennyt ulalle, minä en maksaa yhtään senttiä, en.
Hui hai, sanoi Heikki Kindula, kiitoksia kansanradiolle.
Nimimerkki kyllästynyt, autoet, opeet alkaa ajamaan, ne olet liikennettivät tätä voikaa paljon, etteikö ta osaa ajaa? Menkää koulua.
Kaan ottamaan ohjat käsiin ja tehdä jotain polttoaineen suhteen. Minulla olisi erittäin hyvä keino.
Rekkamiesten pitäisi nyt sulkea Helsinki Turku moottoritie tai Helsinki Lahti moottoritie.
Siitä pitäisi ilmoittaa radion välityksellä, minun mielestä sopiva aika olisi joku perjantai ja kello kaksitoista.
Eiköhän hallitusurru pääsi miettimään polttoaineen hintoja? Toivon, että joku rekka virma kuulee tämän ja ryhtyy toimiin.
Eläkeläisautoilija siis laittoi meille sellaisen viestin, Merja ja sen mies puolestaan kommentoivat edellistä lähetystä, mitä jäi puuttumaan.
Yle se on edelleen puolueellinen media, mitä tulee esimerkiksi luettavien sähköpostien valikointiin.
Aiemmin lähettämäämme postia ei luettu, sillä siinähän hieman kritisoitiin musiikkiohjelmien päällekkäisyyttä.
Sen sijaan kyllä luettavaksi kelpasi viesti, missä arvosteltiin persuja ja mainittiin toki rasistikorttikin.
Ylen arvostelu osui näemmä omaan nilkkaan, joten se niistä sähköposteista, tällaisen viestin laittanut Merja ja sen mies.
Kansaradio.
No, täältä Tampereelta soittelen, kun siinä oli äsken semmoinen herra Kansaradiossa, joka ihmetteli, kun ei ole ilmasia kissoja.
Ne ihmiset, kisayhdistykset, jotka niitä kissoja pyydystää, niin ne tekee vapaaehtoistyötä ja siitä syvä kumarus ja hatunnosto näille ihanille ihmisille, jotka niitä pyydystelee.
Ku maatiloilla on vieläkin paljon niitä populaatiokissoja.
Ja sitten niiden kissojen pito ei suinkaan oo ilmasta, että kaikki hygieniätarvikkeet ja kissan pitopaikan huokrat ja sähköt ja vedet, ne ei oo suinkaan ilmaisia.
Ja sitten pääosin kissat loukutetaan, tosiaan, ja sitten ne saa kaikki loishäädot, ja sitten ne sirutetaan, ja rokotetaan, ja hammas hoidetaan, ja se ei kylläkään oo todellakaan ilmasta.
Sitten aikuiset kissat kastroidaan ja sterilisoidaan, ja nää kaikki niinku tehdään sen yhdistyksen puolesta.
Sitten jokaisen, joka harkitsee sitä kissan ottamista, niin täytyy myöskin huomioida, että kissa ei tule oleen ilmanen eläin.
Se vaatii sen hieka ja laadukkaan ruuan, ja sitten täytyy varautua eläinlääkkäreihin, jotka ei todellakaan oo halpoja tänä päivänä.
Tämmöstä mä vaan, että täytyy harkita sitten kaikkia niitä puolia, mitä se kissan ottaminen tuo tullessaan, mutta siitä saa kyllä niin kivan kumppanin, että siitä on paljon iloa.
No se on kyllä totta, siis pelkästään se, kun avaa kotiovensa, toki sama pätee myös koirin, ja se on niin pyyteitön ilo sitten monesti, mikä tulee.
Niin on, kyllä, joo, ja sitten saa niinku seuraa siitä, jos on yksinäinenkin ihme, ja missa tottuu kyllä hyvimpiä lapsia, osaa väistää lapsia, että jos lapset on pieniä, niin kyllä lapsiperheeseen sopii myöskin kissa.
Lokinista suurin osa on kauhean arkoja, kun ne tulee uuteen kotiin, mutta rauhalisella ja pitkäjänteisellä hoidolla niistä saa kyllä kivan kumppanin.
Se on juuri näin. Sinulla on kissa.
Mulla on kissa, mulla on aina ollut kissoja.
No nii. Kissalle kaikkein tärkein tehtävä on tietysti se, että siinä vaiheessa, kun ihminen rupeaa nukkumaan, niin alkaa kissan vahtivuoroja pitää juosta ympäri.
Se on totta, kyllä. Tänä aamunakin heräsin siihen, että kissa pesi korvaani.
No se kaitaa olla kyllä se kohtelias huomautus, että nyt tuon ruoka jo melkein kohta myöis.
No näin on, kyllä, totta.
Palvelija ylös, kiitos. Hei, hyvä, kun soitit tänne. Minä kiitää, ja toivotaan oikein hyvää sunnuntaijatkoa.
Kiitos, samoi.
Mai.
Juu, vanha mummo on valmiina. Juu, ei minulla muuta, mutta, kun tässä taanoin, eräs roua valitteli sitä, että nuo television säätiedotuksen lukijat tai esittelijät ni tuota liikkuvat edestakaisin.
Muistan, millä sanoilasan sanomatta liikkuvat siinäni.
Eikö tämä roua ole koskaan kuullut työpaikkaliikunnasta? He, he, ei tässä muuta, kiitos, hei.
No, Martti täällä hyvää lauantainaamupäivää.
Joitaki kuukausia sitten mä soitin Kansanradioa, ja kerroin, että Yhdysvaltaen residentti Donald Trump, Rampilla ei ole Iranin vastaisee sotaa, YK, Mantarttia, ja mun sanomaa ei silloin Kansanradiossa julkaistu, mutta nyt Yle julkaisee uutisia, että YK suuttaa Yhdysvaltoja sotarikoksista, että olin oikealla jäljillä.
Mutta puhetani ei silloin otettu todesta, ei muuta, hei, hei.
No, se on kukkonenvekko.
Päivää?
Tota, siitä tuli ensimmäisenä pisa-asia koulusta.
Elikkä tämähän on päivänselevä asia, kännykät ja tämä some ja energia juomat.
Tesä on syy, ja onneksi koulu on tullu vähän rotia tähän kännykän käyttöön, mutta tämä someissa oloja, sitten jatkuvaa kännykää hitlaaminen, kouluja oluko poilessa, se energia juomat.
Se tekee nuorelle rauhoittamaksi, se ei pysty keskittymään, ku se koko ajan on se some mielessä, ja energia juomat tällökkia pitää olla käessä, ku päästetään koulustaan tuotaan.
Tesä on se syy, miksi pisa-tulokset on nii huonoja.
Ja sitten tuota, tässä eräs nainen purnaisatta, ku on kaupassa hädelmät raakoja, siis osa on sen takia raakoja, että, kun kuljetusketju on jostakin tuolta Etelä-Amerikasta, Afrikasta, lämpivistä maista, ja jos sen sieltä lähetetään kypsinä pakataan, ne on pilalla, kun ne on täällä Suomessa, siksi ne osa on raakoja, ku se kuljetusketju on nii pitkä.
Hei muuta, kiitos, hei.
Amerikasta aloittaa viestinsä Tapsa Etelä-Pohjanmaan maaseudulta.
Kyllä minä nii mieleni pahoitin, kun luin maaseudun tulevaisuudesta, että liito-oraville on rakennettu hyppy-tolppia, ja vieläpä maksettu suuria summia.
Kenen lompakosta lienee löytynyt, kun, hyvinvointialueelta typistetään rahaa ja tiet huutavat kunnostusta.
Lähetin kyseisen lehden mielipideosastolle kommentin, mutta eivät julkaiseet, kun arvostelin hankkeen keksiää, joko hulluksi tai humalaiseksi.
Vaan odottelemaan, että koska he keksivät, että kuukkelit tarvitsevat kiitoradan.
Tapsa Etelä-Pohjanmaan maaseudulta.
Kylähän meille sähköpostin lisäksi on tullut paljonkin puheluita siitä, että miten ne hyvin rajalliset varat tällä hetkellä pitäisi käyttää.
Ehdotusta, käskyä, ihmettelyä ja manaamistakin, eli eräälaista kansanradiolaisten varjobudjettia.
Helena täältä Kangasalta, hei.
Helena, tervehdys.
Kuule, oon kuunnellu kaiken aikaa kaikkia Ylen ohjelmia, mutta hirmusen vähän on tullu.
Näistä leikkauksista on ollut puhetta, mutta kukaan ei oo oikein isoon ääneen maininnu, että Lapissa pelastushelikopteri Aslak on ollut jo heinäkuusta asti maassa.
Oha, okei.
Potilaita, sairaalahan, millä käydään etsimässä, kadonneita sieltä erämaasta, taikka jos tulee metsäpaloja, niin osallistutaan siihen hommaa.
Toiminta ollut, taavoilat piti tässä nyt ihan samalla metsästä tietoa, neljäs heinäkuuta lähtien.
Joo, nii, semmoinen käsitys mullakin on. Ite luin sen uutisen 22. päiväheinäkuuta lehdestä. Se riipas kyllä hyvin syvältä sielusta, koska vuosi sitten 21. päiväheinäkuuta mun mies jouduttii lennattaen Pellon terveyskeskuksesta Ouluun.
Sillä samaisella Aslakilla. Eli ilman sitä Aslakia olisin tällä hetkellä leski. Se sattui kyllä niin syvälle, kun mä sen uutisen luin, ja sen tähden mä oon sitä seurannu, ja oon hämmästelyt, kun näistä kaikista muista.
Enkä mä nyt vähättele näiden kaikkien järjestöjen toimintaa, mutta mun mielestäni toi Aslak on kyllä hirmuisen tärkeä.
Ette joku määrä, kun on rahaa, kun pohditaan, mihin se laitetaan, niin Aslakista, Aslakin kohdalla ei pitäiti leikata.
Nii, olen sitä mieltä, kun ajatelee, että se on nyt ollut jo näin pitkään, että sittenkö vasta tilanne muuttuu, kun jonkun päättäjän omainen katkasee jalkansa jossain tiettömän taipaleen takana, taikka saa jonkun kohtauksen, että pitää lennättää Aslakilla jostain tulilta sitten sairaalaa.
Ja mä haluan kyllä nyt tässä kohtaa sitten lähettää ihan sydämelliset kiitokset Kolarin terveyskeskuksen toiminnalle silloin vuosi sitten 21. päivä heinäkuulta, ja näille helikopterilentäjille, ja Oulun yliopistolliseen sairaalaan.
Me saatiin, siis miestä hoidettiin äärettemmä hyvin, ja minua kohdeltiin hirmuisen hyvin, niinkuin omaisena.
Tiedät, kuinka hyvä ja tärkeä se apu ja hoito voi olla, ja toivois sitä sitten muillekin?
Ehdottomasti, kyllä, joo.
Kiitokset välitetty, ja minä kiitän, kun soitit aiheesta.
Kiitoksia sulle, ja hyvää syksyä.
Samoin kiitos, samoin, samoin.
Kiitos, hei hei.
Moi, sanokaa nyt, mulle tyhmälle, tämä asia, että, kun Suomi lähetti taas Ukrainaa 290 miljoonaan paketin, ja kokonaisumma on jo 3,6 miljardii, se on 3600 miljoonaa.
Ni, mistä ne rahat tulee, ja otetaan, hei?
Ku Purra huutaa, jauhaa tuolla koko ajan, että, ei oo rahaa, ei oo rahaa, ei oo rahaa, täytyy leikata.
Tää on ihan uskomatonta toimintaa.
Ja sitten tää tohne juttu, nytko F-35 tulee?
Nyt kymmenen miljardii, mistä ne rahat sitten tulee?
Onko siellä näillä joku roopeankan, joku rahasäiliö sitten vai?
Voi Juma, sanokaa mulle tyhmälle, moi.
No, se oi Jartsa, täältä Turusta soittelee. Minä vaan tuota ihmettelee, että tuo ruotsi entinen pääministeri oli ihan oikeassa, että jos kansalta leikataan köyhältä kansalta, niin se on hyvin häkkiä rikkaiden pankkitilille, ja näihän se on käynyt.
Nyt ne vaeltaa, tuolako ne on saanut häätöjä tällä Turussakin, tuolla rappukäytävissä, ja siinä on moraali menny, ne varastaa ja ritsaa, ja ei muutako vankipaikkoja lisää.
Yhtä paljon menee rahaa, tuomasiinko vankiloita rakennetaan, ja sitten sairaita ihmisiä sinne rahataan mukaa, ei se oo mikään hoitopaikka.
Ainakko leikataan, köyhiltä, tai vähävaraisilta. Niinkö nyt on käynyt? Tietenki se onko oikeistohallitus, ni sehän ammentaa rikkaile.
Tä se on, aa, ei, se oo millään tavalla oikeuden mukaista. Hei, hei.
Mää ihmettele, mä, ku lukee tekstiteevätä esimerkiksi, suomalaiset tyytyväisiä soteen.
Ja joka paikkakunnalla puhutaan, kun terveyskeskukset on siirtynyt kauas, ja eikä saa palveluja.
Onks tää joku, en mä ymmärrä, onks tää joku kokoomuksen, ja perussuomalaisten tämmönen jonkin näkön, onks ne maksanu tuonne ylelle, että ne laittaa tämmösiä viestejä.
Täähän on ihan kauheeta. Sit lopet, pitäs lopettaa, sitten koko terveydenhuolto, ni sitten ois kaikki tosi tyytyväisiä. Eipä muuta, kiitos.
Nimimerkki tarkkana kuin porkkana kysyy, että eikö toimittajat tiedä, paljonko kello on?
Aika useasti maikkarilla ja myös ylellä toimittajat sanoo hyvää iltaa ennen kello kahdeksatoista, koska iltahan alkaa vasta kello kahdeksantoista.
Ei millään pahalla, mutta, näin siis terveisin, tarkkana kuin porkkana.
Toisessa viestissä puolestaan kysytään, että ettekö te iskelmämusiikin tekijät ymmärrä, että miten ikävää on kuunnella tätä nykymusiikkia, kun sen musiikki metelin takaa ei, laulu vikinästä saa yhtään mitään selvää, kysyn vaan.
Ja, jos näihin tai nyt seuraaviin kysymyksiin haluaa vastata, niin minä niiden jälkeen noita yhteystietoja taas kertaan.
Nimerkki mie mie, voiko tekoäly kaapata Jumalan?
No eihän se voi Jumalaa kaapata tekoäly, mutta se voi puhua niinkö sitä tavalla, että hän olisi mukaa Jumala.
Ja ennen kuin suurin suuri viisaus ja hyvä tahto laskeutuu tänne meidän maapallollemme, niin sitä ennen tulee tämmönen valheen lapsi, eksyttäjä.
Sitä ennen tulee juuri tällainen valheen lapsi ja eksyttäjä.
Ja, jos katotaan, tieteelliseltä kannalta, eli tekoäly ei ole läheskään, tuota, niin se ei välttämättä kehitä meitä, varsinkaan nuoria, sinne ajattelun puolen.
Mie mie ja hyvää, hyvää, hyvää, hyvää, hyvää tulevaa, syksyä kaikille.
Nyt tuon paha tilanne. Eläkelaiset ei mitään muuta kuin jaksa valittaa.
Koska tulee meidän työmiesten aika? Kysyn vaan.
No, pohoja maalta päin päivää.
Oosko, miten ne nuo eduskunnan ihmisille, niinko jos pantas semmoinen laki, että neki, jotka siellä oo vastaan, noista polttoaineja, halavennuksesta, kun ne ajaa tuommoisilla halavalla sähköautoilla, joista ei makseta ehkä.
Veroa ja maantieliikenteen veroa, niinku nykyään maksetaan, näistä polttoaineautoveroista.
Mitähän, montakohan niitä on niitä semmoista autoilijaa siellä eduskunnassa, joilla ei oo vielä sähköautoa?
Ja sitten ne joutuis nyt ajamaan kaikki tuolla nykyisen polttoaineihinnalla, kun tällä hetkellä on pensahintakin jo 2,5 euroa yli.
Et tuota, oiskohan ne nii tuota räävä suihia sitten tuolla puhkuissaan, kun nyt ovat. Kiitos.
Edelä mainittuihin kysymyksiin, jos siis haluaa vastata, niin minäpä kerron ihan juuri yhteystiedot. Minun tosin tekee itsemieli sitä ennen esittää yksi kysymys.
Eli, mikä paikkakunta tunnetaan myös nimellä iloisten mummojen kaupunki?
Kun ihan lopuksi kuullaan, vielä television ja radionkin liittyvää puheenvuoroa, ja yksi soittaja kertoi soittavansa iloisten mummojen kaupunkista, enkä ole taannut tuollaista aikaisemmin kuulla.
Mutta, ne yhteystiedot, Whatsapp viestit numeroon 044 55 154 64.
Sähköpostia osoitteeseen, kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Käsinkirjoitettua viestiä osoitteeseen, kansanradio, PL 79 00 00 24, Yleisradio.
Ja se vastaajan numero on 08 00 154 64.
Ja tämän lähetyksen jälkeen, siis suunnuntaina kello 12:30 alkaen, kun soitat siihen numeroon, niin minä, eli siis ihmis vastaa ja vastaa, voit kertoa, että mihin asiaan ihmisten, siis meidän suomalaisten pitäisi kiinnittää enemmän huomiota.
Sis sen lisäksi, että kaikkien nyt pitäisi muistaa nauttia sateisista syysilloista, niin kauan kuin kalenteri sen sallii.
Harva asia nimittäin on maailmassa yhtä kaunis ja rauhoittava kuin sateinen syysilta kotisuomessa.
Lasse Olkinoara toivottaa oikein hyvää juuri tätä hetkeä.
Kansanradio.
Ja, näsää täältä Toivakan peltojen keskeltä soittelee. Vähän myräkkää pitellyjä näin pois päin.
No niin, tuolla ku käveli, niin ei tarvinnu oikeastaan melkein jalkoja liikuttaa. Tuuli kuljetti.
Joo. Semmoisen asian tiimoilta soittelen, tota noinen. Esimerkiks, televisiouutiset, ku haastatellaan jotai ulkomaa elävää, ja siihen tulee käännösteksti siihen alareo, niin jostain kautta johonkin toivomusta, että voisi saada siihen käännöstekstin taustaan mustaks.
Käännöstekstin taustaan mustaks, ni sitten sen käännöstekstin myös näkee.
Niin, ku useisti on haastateltavilla on valkoinen teepaita.
Joo.
Nyt eihän siinä valkoista tekstiä oikein tahon näe.
No se, se on kyllä totta.
Ku siinä alareunassa, alareunassa menee kuitenkin se tekstinauha menee, ja siinä on niinku sillee on musta teksti ja valkoinen pohja, ja näin pois.
Nin miksei sitä käännöstekstiä voisi saada samanlaiseksi, että tausta mustaks.
Hautta valkoiseksi, jos on, no, mitenkä se on se teksti siinä.
Nii, olisi mukava myös lukea tai siis ymmärtää, että mitä mistä puhutaan.
Nii, nii. Kyllä hätäisesti ite saa vielä selvää, mutta tota noin, kun on vielä iäkkäämpiäki ihmisiä, niin tuota.
Nii.
Tämmösellä toiveella vaan täältä.
Kansanradion kautta toive heille, jotka tästä vastuus.
Hyvä, ku soitit.
Kiitos.
Minä toivon hyvää tuulisen päivän jatkoa.
Joo, ei muuta kuin ollaan tuulessa ja tuiverruksessa.
Näin o, näin o.
No ni, kiitos, hei.
Iloisten mummojen kaupungista yks mummo soittaa todella, todella pahoillani siitä, että tanssi tähtien kanssa ohjelmassa paras suoritus putosi, joka oli harmoninen, joka kosketti ihan kotona, että niinku tanssi kuuluu ollakin.
Tunsin, että olen niinku heidän kanssa mukana siellä, mutta tämä nykytanssihan on vain tätä hillitöntä hyppelyä halutun tavaran ympärillä, ja tanssipaikat ovat kuin raviratoja urheiluvaatteista kulkevien ihmisten.
Ei mulla muuta, ois pakiva saaha joskus vanha ajan tanssi.
Tarko, verätää, terve.
Semmosta rupea su soittelemaan, ku tota, tämän TV-ohelmaa katou, ku siellä ei oo, nää, sama tyypi tän kanava tää toiselle, nää, ahkosaareluomet, nää, saa, tän, veonas, nurtmoima, mikäs on, tienani.
Siel on paljon muita, kitikokko, se, kata ja tätä.
Ei, kyllä, nää, muuta hommaa, ku nää, hänisee, vielä, ku tuothan näitä, samoja, kai tyyppiä työrittää, jo, kanava ohelmasta toise.
Ka ei kyläsyttämään katse. Minä en opettanut MTL:n, mussen kato muutu mun uutise.
Tä, tämmösiä taidinoita vähän ilmittelee, kuka ei mulle et ole kurnannuudeleta MTL:n ohelmia.
Tä, tämmönen tasina.
Kiitoksia.
Heippa, Aune Heinolesta.
Semmonen juttu, että näissä avalieluonto-ohelmissa pitää olla mies pelosta, ja, että on selkeää, eikä tällainen pieni naisääni, mistä ei ota mitään silmää.
Kiitos, kiitos.
Tunnin väle olevia.
Mitä, mitä, mitä tekemättömät uutiset, että pitäis uutiset vaan vahittää viis minuuttia, enintään kymmenen minuuttia pitkät.
Kiitos niistä, pysäs järkee, että mitä niissä puhuta, yleensä. Kiitos sulle, hei hei.
TV-mainokset Suomen televisiossa on mennyt kyllä aivan äärimmäisyyksiin.
Siellä on vaippamainoksia, vähävelijää, Google-vaippamainoksia, joka ei välttämättä kuuluu asiaan ensinkään.
Siellä on paljon muita, pizzamainoksia, vähävelijää, semmoisia on kansakunnalia, lihavuus lisätää edintäsairaimassa.
Tähän TV-mainoksesta saattava rajoituksia, semmoiset roskamanoksesta tuhotaan, ihmisiä syömään, iltamyyhenä syömään, syödään, yötä vasta syödään itsensä sairaiksi,
ja nukkuvat huonosti, ei pysty työlämään, paino nousee, ja ruosee kohtuuttomasti.
Tää television toiminta on mennyt aivan ihan vallattomassa, siellä on jatkuvasti hirviät määrät myös urheiluohjelmaa.
Sitä urheilusta on tullut kauhea epäjumalasta, se on tärkeintä ku kaikki muu.
Samoiten veikkaus on myös samaa mallita, veikataan vaan urheiluiden hyväksi,
ja niin paljon on patu numeroja mukaan veikkauksessa, että ei varmasti osuus enää, aina numeromäärää lisää,
että kukaan ei saisi oikeastaan mitään.
Kansakuntaa köyhytetään, köyhyvä kansakunta yrittää, monet veikkausel saa, ilaikä ni saa apua,
muualta enää jo ri mistää oikeastaan apua saa, ja työttömyyttä on vielä niin paljon.
Ikävä kyllä, tämä tilanne on Suomessa ollut suorastaan alas ajoa, suorastaan ihan paljolti tahallisesti.